Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Patrizia C Romeo Tomasini
Matteo Caccia:
Partiamo da questo video,
perché ho letto che
- è stata una sorta di terapia,
preparare questo intervento?
Francesca Fedeli: Sì, è stata una terapia
perché venivamo da due anni
in cui eravamo molto riferiti
soltanto alla malattia.
Vedevamo persone soltanto in funzione
di aggiustare qualcosa di rotto,
o di risolvere un problema.
E invece preparare il video
è stato davvero
ripercorrere la nostra storia
e aprirci un po'.
Fino, appunto, ad arrivare lì,
salire sul palco, e parlarne da zero
- nessuno sapeva della nostra storia,
prima - e parlarne a tutti.
M.C.: E anche il vostro intervento
ha una storia strana:
voi, di fatto, avevate fatto richiesta
per partecipare
tra il pubblico, in realtà.
E poi cos'è successo?
F.F.: In realtà sì: come avviene
per tutti gli eventi TED,
anche per gli eventi globali
si fa domanda di partecipazione
e loro devono decidere
se accettarti o no.
E poi è partita una mail
che è arrivata al mattino
in cui si chiedeva
se, fra i partecipanti,
c'era qualcuno che aveva
una storia da raccontare.
Per cui Roberto ha applicato,
dicendo lo stesso messaggio
che era un po' la conclusione del video:
considera quello che hai come un dono
e lavora soprattutto sulle opportunità.
M.C.: Che è un po' come dire:
voglio iscrivermi a una scuola;
no, vieni a fare l'insegnante.
Più o meno il livello era quello.
F.F.: Sì, è stato così.
M.C.: Che anno era?
F.F.: 2013.
M.C.: Sono passati tre anni
e mezzo, più o meno.
Cos'è successo, in questi anni?
F.F.: Beh, è successo un mondo.
Innanzitutto prima eravamo soli,
quando ci avete visto lì;
e poi si è aperto
un altro mondo di persone.
Appena abbiamo detto:
"Noi abbiamo questo problema",
altre persone con problemi simili,
traumi legati a malattie
entrate in famiglia,
hanno detto: "be', si: anche noi
ce li abbiamo e l'abbiamo risolto così."
Per cui abbiamo creato
un po' un movimento,
e oggi siamo circa 500 genitori
che soltanto in Italia hanno manifestato
di avere questo problema.
Quindi persone che prima non avevano
una struttura di riferimento,
o non si potevano scambiare
informazioni fra loro.
E poi l'altra cosa che è successa
è quello che avete visto voi
- il prendere la penna con Mario
e appunto attivare quello che è
il meccanismo dei neuroni specchio -
in realtà adesso
è diventato un protocollo,
è diventato qualcosa di reale
perché le prime 30 famiglie
hanno aderito al progetto,
e adesso siamo portando avanti appunto
un progetto pilota, con il CNR,
di riabilitazione proprio basata
sul meccanismo dei neuroni specchio.
M.C.: E come sta Mario?
F.F: Eh, Mario sta bene, direi.
[Mario saluta]
Eh, giusto per manifestare che sta bene!
(Applausi)
M.C.: Senti, prima di salutarti
e di farti tornare alla tua famiglia:
dei vari progetti che avete fatto
- Fightthestroke,
Call for brain, Mirrorable -
vuoi raccontarcene uno in particolare,
vuoi dirci a cosa state lavorando adesso?
F.F.: Adesso stiamo
lavorando a Mirrorable,
quindi il rendere concreta
una possibilità di riabilitazione
per persone che hanno
avuto un impairment,
un problema di tipo motorio
soprattutto agli arti superiori.
Quindi in questo senso Mirrorable
è una piattaforma di riabilitazione
che espone i bambini a dei video,
costruiti secondo
particolari accorgimenti,
e poi permette loro di riabilitarsi,
quindi di mettere in pratica
l'esercizio che hanno imparato:
- nel primo caso erano
degli esercizi di magia
insegnati loro dal mago Walter Rolfo -
permette a quel punto
di connettersi con un altro bambino
e metterle in pratica fra pari.
Quindi diciamo che la più grande
soddisfazione di questi giorni
- perché il pilota è partito
proprio adesso, a dicembre-
è vedere che quello che era
un social stigma, un problema,
un qualcosa di cui vergognarsi,
è diventato un modo di essere orgogliosi.
Questi bambini adesso sono orgogliosi
di invitare persone a casa,
e far vedere come fanno
i giochi di magia.
M.C: Senti - e poi
ti lascio davvero andare.
Quando succede una cosa del genere,
immagino che la propria vita si resetti.
Cioè, di fatto tutto
diventa meno importante.
Però immagino anche che ci sia
una forma di sconforto,
di paura profondissima:
lo racconta Roberto, nel video.
Qual è stata la scintilla
che vi ha fatto dire:
non stiamo quaggiù,
e cerchiamo di rialzarci?
È successo qualcosa?
Vi siete detti qualcosa?
F.F.: Probabilmente è stato
qualcosa che noi adesso, razionalmente,
attribuiamo a quel momento lì.
È stata l'esperienza
di dire a un certo punto:
non vediamo risultati
della terapia tradizionale,
quindi prendiamoci un momento
di distacco, di evasione.
Per noi è stato riprendere
a fare la vita di prima.
Quindi abbiamo detto:
ricominciamo a viaggiare,
a sentire musica.
E proprio in uno di questi viaggi
ci siamo resi conto che Mario migliorava.
Ha iniziato a camminare
proprio in un momento
in cui eravamo in viaggio,
in una situazione di evasione.
Quindi, probabilmente,
ogni tanto resettare,
godendosi un po' di più il quotidiano,
e non pensando invece all'impatto -
M.C: Alle terapie, ha aiutato.
Grazie ancora: Francesca Fedeli,
Roberto d'Angelo.
(Applausi)
Grazie, complimenti.